well we'll have a discussion running
perhaps 45 minutes or closer to an hour
I want to leave time for questions from
the audience when you do have questions
and please make sure they're questions
not speeches approach we have a
microphone at the bottom of each aisle
you'll need to actually speak into the
microphone to be recorded I'd like to
start with you Donna your series top
secret America an absolutely chilling
description of a kind of national
security concerns and bureaucracy run
amok I think you said that you know
tapping into the funds released after
9/11 there's something like twelve
hundred and seventy one government
organizations in 1931 private companies
working on counterterrorism or related
things you and William Arkin the
co-writer took two years to gather all
this material how did you get the idea
for it and how did you go about
assembling all that information well
briefly I'd covered intelligence and the
military after 9/11 and when we got done
trying to figure out what had happened
on 9/11 who al-qaida was we eventually
started saying well what's the
government doing what is the government
doing to try to fight this war that was
now called the global war on terrorism
and unlike the military which is a
relatively open organization compared to
the intelligence world you couldn't find
out because it was all classified all of
it was classified so you know that's the
secrecy veil that we were up against but
managed to write about the CIA from any
year
in other parts of it and then at a
certain point bill and I who have been
colleagues for a long time just on the
phone talking a lot about what we're
seeing and what what do you think it is
and that sort of thing said you know
there's something that's going on here
that's very big and it's structural it's
it's probably permanent you know we I
can feel it wherever I was the number of
organizations the number of the
proliferation of code names of you know
slang for this and that the unit's well
why don't we try to figure out how to
map it because and how did the scribe
huge thing which was big because the
military is large and there are 18 in
intelligence agencies within the
government and so we took a long time
trying to figure out well how did we do
that and we decided based on in part an
experience that I had doing the black
sites knowing that even if you're the
CIA you can put a cover-up over over
things that you're trying to keep secret
but everything lives somewhere you know
it doesn't live in the clouds lives here
on the earth and so we said well what if
we then did sort of a mapping of our own
of what we came to call an alternative
geography of the United States it is
sort of mapping the DNA of the secret
world and we started at the secret level
cloud on looking for units and
organizations and companies that did
work for the government at the secret
level this is one kind of classification
and we we found so many that we said
well we're never going to be able to get
through this so let's elevate it to the
top secret level which is much more
difficult because that is actually a
huge legal but sorry do you know how do
you even get the names of the companies
in the organism well it was um I'll tell
you a couple of their hey one fun story
about that I mean some of them is were a
process of just taking the organizations
that we knew bill is a self-described
obsessive compulsive person who loves to
look at budgets and lists and so he
he routinely looks at the minutiae of
government that most people don't look
at and if there's an anomaly you know he
could spot it and so he would trace it
you'd put a little card into a secret
units box and for years he would you
know go through and try to find these
things so it just give you one example
he had a name of an organization that he
was convinced was a secret organization
and so I got the address and I went to
Crystal City were is located and we knew
the street and the name and the floor it
was located on because he had records of
wiring contracts that would wire
fiber-optic cables from one office to
another and so he knew that there was a
triangle of wires between this
organization a very secret organization
in the pentagon and another building by
the same organization in another place
in Crystal City so I went looking for we
even knew what floor it was on and went
into a lobby I was looking for the the
15th floor and the lobby had a directory
that scrolled was it was an electronic
one the scrolled the names of everything
in the building and this stopped on the
14th floor and I was looking for the
15th floor and so I went up and I got
onto the elevator and I saw that there
was a 15th floor button so I pushed it
and I went up and you know ready for who
knows what but found a janitor instead
vacuuming the carpet and went around the
corner and there was the door with the
sign and the camera that you know looked
at you and the warning signs to go away
and all that and then I did the same
thing for another building which was
also in this triangle and again the
marquee outside this is an Air Force
mainly an Air Force building had a lot
of the names for different Air Force
organizations but nowhere was the
defense policy analysis office again it
didn't exist and and so slowly we
learned if I went back to the Crystal
City place that I had gone through many
times reporting about the military
I now started looking at marquees and
then these big giant buildings like 15
stories tall and then have nothing on
the marquee
except you know Joe's pizza place which
was downstairs and so I would feed him
addresses he would do his thing on Eno's
deep web searching which is something
you know everybody should learn how to
do better and with contracts with
paperwork with a lot of interviews that
I did with people that I'd either known
for a long time in the intelligence
world you have to kind of accumulate
sources over a long period of time who
pointed in other directions we came up
with over two years time a map that
actually pinpoints where it all is and
then we tried to figure out what all
these things did not not in any real
granular level but what do they work on
generally and then you'll see on our
website which it has which is Washington
Post com slash top-secret America you
can play around with the database that
shows you where how many things work on
X Y & Z and you'll see one of the big
patterns that we found was redundancy
that this thing had not just grown in
fact it had doubled in size in most
places than prior to 9/11 but that the
money was flowing so quickly that no one
really paid much attention to where it
was going if you had an idea you could
get it funded and therefore what
developed is a huge redundancy in almost
any place you can imagine yeah and so
that we in fact we may have a chart or
two that ran with the story if we could
throw that up I think they're kind of
amazing it shows all right there you are
like look at that for a Rube Goldberg
yeah action and the idea behind the
story and why I described it as killing
is there are so many agencies and
there's redundancy compartmentalization
and everything that no one can possibly
get a handle
it's like drinking from a firehose
instead of a glass of all general
clapper who is now the Director of
National Intelligence he actually said
that there is one person who knows it
all and that's God yeah it certainly
wasn't created by God did you at any
time just you know when you had to
verify the information I know you you
interviewed the defense secretary gates
did anyone say please don't publish this
or pull publish marksmen and did you
hold anything back oh we did anything
you know I mean yes the national
security 114 what you're balancing is
things that really need to be kept
secret either because lives are at stake
an operation that's not controversial
and you know clearly doesn't cross some
line is at stake and a whole other realm
of things that really are described on a
case-by-case basis and it's hard to
imagine unless you're getting into that
realm so in all cases where I have
something that is obviously secret the
government feels that it's they make it
secret they classified for a legitimate
reason that's what you know again that's
what they are doing they are trying to
work to do it for a legitimate reason
because it would damage national
security is what the rules are then I
always tell them what it is that we have
and so that they can make an argument
that if you publish this whatever
argument they want to make and in this
case they did make an argument that many
the number of details that we have had
would would be damaging and for us the
and actually they said don't publish it
and we say well we're we're going to
publish it can you be a little more
helpful and try to explain what your
concerns are and we didn't get very far
um and did you hold stuff out well we
definitely held stuff out but we did
that because when we we internally
discussed you know what it would be we
had some what I'd call consigliere as
people who are in the who've been in
intelligence but are no longer there and
also really value what the post does to
talk through the various aspects and
could we be setting people up for
damaging you know results that we didn't
want to do and what we always have to do
is we walk as far up to the line of
giving readers information that has
detailed to make the story authentic
because if you notice there aren't very
many people quoted in it we walk up to
that line without hopefully crossing it
and one damaged any national security
things but also not gratuitously putting
details and that that are in that
category of classified so you know it's
it's really what we're trying to do to
make our stories you're comfortable with
it you feel nothing in your articles
really was ended up being all that
sensitive or partly that there there was
a big hoopla over it because for one it
put all the names of the companies
together and the companies didn't like
that even though this is a base on
unclassified information which is
another interesting dynamic that we can
hopefully talk about in WikiLeaks is at
the same time they're classifying things
like ridiculous things in some cases
there is enormous amount of clues out
there on the web and elsewhere that can
lead you to lead you along a trail that
we took so the government has no idea
what is out there and to be had
yeah they don't even know Adam in your
in your documentary you concentrated on
a 31 year old man Henry Glover what
happened to him can you just tell us
briefly his story and why you chose him
to tell a larger story yes so what Henry
Glover was 30 year old man 31 year old
man who was a father of four and it was
shortly after Hurricane Katrina and what
we understand is that he
was going to get some goods that have
been taken from a dime store they were
pots and pans and candles and stuff and
he was shot by a police officer near
that dime store he sought help his
brother and a Good Samaritan another
person rushed him for help and one thing
that didn't go in the documentary that's
worth saying now is this was on the west
bank of the Mississippi after Hurricane
Katrina so it didn't flood there but
there was no power there was no water
the conditions were really rough and it
was within New Orleans proper and the
closest hospital was across the parish
line in the next parish over and there
was a barricade there and they couldn't
get through because there was law
enforcement the Sheriff's Department set
up there
so this was a group of four black men in
a car one of whom had just been shot and
the driver said we have four black men
in the car we are not going to get
through into the largely white
neighboring parish and we're going to go
to the closest place I think we can get
help and that is to this police
encampment up the street at a at a
school they didn't realize that Henry
had been shot by a police officer and so
they sped him to this SWAT team outpost
the SWAT team had taken over this
elementary school and they showed up
there and they thought that hey these
guys they know CPR they can rush them to
the hospital they can treat him here
they probably have medical supplies
they'll help them but they didn't help
them what they did is they physically
attacked the able-bodied men the three
able-bodied men and they left Henry
Glover to bleed to death in the back of
the car and then the officers took Henry
body and the car that the Good Samaritan
had been driving they drove it over
behind another police outpost a police
station parked it on the banks the
Mississippi River set it on fire burned
up Henry's body and left him there and
pretended that he was a piece of rubbish
he was a piece of garbage that he hadn't
been a human and that he didn't matter
and they covered it up for three years
until I started poking into it
and when you when you poked into it you
are clearly running a risk I noticed you
what you even interview the deputy I
guess it was the Deputy Police
Commissioner they must have known you
were what you were looking into did you
have any kind of frightening moments did
you encounter hostility did you get how
did you get people to open up including
his brother who I think was one of the
three wasn't yeah you know there's kind
of two important things here and one is
first it like the bigger challenge
rather than like the awesome like action
movie stuff like getting threatened by
cops that kind of stuff the bigger
challenge honestly it was bureaucratic
and that's how these things often are is
that the secret agent here the secret
weapon was our attorney every single
piece of documentation that we wanted to
get we had to threaten to sue to get so
Laurie Mintz the attorney who worked
with me on on the TV and on the stories
the print stories she was the one who
did a lot of the hard work they didn't
want to give up anything from the
coroner's office
we had to sue them to get the autopsy
report hell about what you were told
when you went to the coroner's you know
so I called the coroner's office and I
wanted to see the autopsies of people
who had died violently after Hurricane
Katrina and I said you know to to the
staff on the at the coroner's office I
said you know would you like me to make
a formal public records request you know
I know this is a public document under
Louisiana law and the staffer said well
you can do that but we don't follow the
law anyway so we sued and prevailed but
that was how everything was with with
the police records with the coroner
reports with everything the second piece
about this sort of fear and of being
menaced by the police honestly I was too
naive to get it like that that I should
be nervous and I had I had uncovered
conspiracies before I had documented
done done reporting that has shown that
police had framed
two innocent men for murder sent them to
prison for 14 years
they were exonerated they were paid
million dollars by the city you know so
I knew that these kind of things
happened and that there were in fact
times when people did incredibly
incredibly damaging things and they
conspired to do them and so forth but I
just didn't get it honestly for about
two years of time in New Orleans and I
would meet these I would meet with like
I met with a source who said you know I
don't want anyone to know I'm meeting
with you because the police will you
know if they find out they'll end up
doing something like planning three
pounds of cocaine in my car I thought
well this person's crazy this person's
watch too much training day you know too
much Serpico and then after I started
interviewing a lot of cops who had
actually done that I realized that you
know I should have been like yeah I was
kind of naive like this actually is how
it goes down in New Orleans yeah yeah uh
what in San Francisco also you were
attracted you wrote all often about
police about social injustice housing
projects what drew you to this as a kind
of specialty is there something in your
background or why are you
why do you dig deeply into this one
particular area we know it's really this
and I've been thinking about it lately
and parsley it was it was early on my
mentoring with sandy close the an
award-winner
here this year that I'm interested in
the stories of people from the ground up
and the stories of people at the bottom
and the stories of people who aren't
being talked to by the media and so that
was the way I've approached all these
stories so my point of entry for doing
the the investigation into what happened
with Henry Glover was really through his
family it wasn't through people at the
top of the police department saying oh
this horrible thing happened and no
one's doing it it was from the very
people at the bottom that no one had had
talked to and if anyone had just gone
and spent time with them and listened to
them they would have seen this story and
that's kind of another kind of secrecy
that there are people that just are not
listened to they just don't get a chance
to communicate their message and that's
what I've tried to do a lot so go with
no into places where others don't
talking to people who
we aren't talked to there's a whole
nother world exactly exam
speaking of starting at the top instead
of the bottom your piece on general
McChrystal had obviously a huge impact
but I read somewhere that you were
surprised by that do you not know what
you had when you printed it and I think
you told Newsweek I'm actually shocked
by the response yeah well one reason I'm
shocked
I was shocked by the response and still
M is that you know I've been covering
the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan for
five years and usually no one cares
about anything you're right and I don't
know I don't mean that ironically it's
just like there's there's there's
jaw-dropping stuff that comes out every
week about what's going on in Iraq and
Afghanistan
that leaves nary a dent in our public
consciousness so my thinking at the time
was I knew it was good material but my
thinking was well you know maybe they'll
talk about on cable for a couple hours
and you know and then I'll go on my
merry way and you know write a book
about that time with a crazy general so
so so I was quite surprised by but I
mean I guess one of one of this is where
I kind of am coming from on the story
was that you know for years doing what
we were working for Newsweek and filing
a lot of reports and filing covering the
war in Iraq what I what I realized what
would happen often is that the most
interesting parts what I felt of my
files and stories were actually being
taken out of what was getting published
and it wasn't that it was you know the
news was always there but it was you
know the offhand comment what people
really say how people really act what it
was really like to be there these sort
of details that I find really
fascinating but they would never really
make it into editors would cut them out
and you thought they were telling detail
and and that is good then I'm probably
rightly so just cuz they didn't they
weren't necessarily didn't fit in in the
medium that I was I was kind of writing
for when I decided to leave Newsweek one
of the things I wanted to do what
capture all those details and one of the
first big stories I did was for GQ where
I went out to this outpost on the border
between Afghanistan and Pakistan with
this to a group of twenty guys and and
talk about people who never no one ever
listens to the the average dope the
private and the specialist he lives his
life not being listened to right and all
of a sudden here's this dude who comes
up and he's like oh wait your job is
just to listen to all the complaints I
have and and in and like unlike my
buddies who heard them for like two
years straight every day since basic
training it's all new to you I'm like
yeah and and and then you're gonna like
put my picture in the magazine yeah
they're like that I having to say a lot
there's a good military reporting coming
out of both shirt Iraq and Afghanistan
in which reporters talk and live with
directly with people during the suit so
not a you know just back to the
gentleman do you think he should have
been fired well all get to the mic but
my point is that that that and that that
outpost in Afghanistan what I did with
these guys was wait was gone guard duty
with them and listen them talk for hours
right and so the idea behind the story
of general McChrystal always had was
well no one's ever really hung out with
these top ranking guys and sort of told
it like like like it was with them and
you know so that's what my sort of thing
shitty I you know should even fired it
that was you know President Obama's
decision and and you know my my thinking
was why did the best or I could do and
and let the just me wait how did you
manage to achieve this kind of
fly-on-the-wall status how did you get
access I know you've said the most
surprising things happened right in the
first 24-48 hours when you met them in
Paris how did you in a way get yourself
into their confidence and did you have
to establish any ground rules at all uh
I didn't have to establish any um but I
mean in this case it was pretty straight
forward I mean it's not that dramatic I
I I wanted to do a profile general
McChrystal for Rolling Stone I emailed
the press guy
hey I'd love to do a profile gentlemen
crystal he said come to Paris next week
is it okay I showed up in Paris and we
sort of said okay and I said here's the
story I'd love to do a story with like
part of you guys hanging out in Paris
and Europe and the other part in Kabul
and then here come on in you know and
and I just sort of followed him around
with a tape recorder and a notepad and
and a lot of the stuff that ended up
getting them that became sort of
controversial was all said within the
first 24-48 hours
so much so that I sort of I knew I kind
of already had my story but then you
know the volcano went off in Iceland and
I kind of got end up getting stuck with
them for longer which was which was
advantageous in the end because I got to
really sense of who they who they were
yeah I've read it now in preparation for
this a couple I mean you know I'd say
four or five times and it's interesting
that quotes from crystal himself are not
really that damning there are three
things he said what about Biden went
about Eikenberry one about not wanting
to receive emails from Holbrooke three
so three of the four times important
people civilian seat range it gives you
a sense well all right no I wouldn't say
was trashing actually well I think might
be damaging quotes came from people
close to him and under him that's not
true that's actually true if you read
the story the most damning quote that's
been that's been quoted by everyone is
Biden Vice President Biden bite me
that's the quote and the reason that
quickly that it wasn't bites me
McChrystal said he said whose bite right
right but but and this is the point that
general McChrystal uh in that scenario
was the first one who started making fun
of Vice President Biden and let the door
open for the for the comments to follow
so so this idea that it was just his
aide saying this stuff well III didn't
sure that I did say it was just as aides
I said it's interesting that a lot of
the materials seem to have come from
people under him I don't think that
makes it invalid anyway
maybe even about but many of them
weren't quoted by name so you must have
said I won't quote you on this or this
is off the record in fact did you say
though we had their name we had I had
their names in the original draft but my
editors took them out for like
readability reasons so uh you know and
there were occasions when they did they
did say his stuff was off the record and
if I would have published that that
would have been a real a real story but
I stuck to you know I mean I one of
these sort of interesting aspects to the
story and going back I have a book
that's coming out about it and I was
going back instead of listening to my
first interviews with them and and you
know my first interview gentleman
crystal I have it's sort of really
amazing moment on on tape where the
press divider says oh Michael is going
to be hanging out with us for the next
couple days in Paris and gentleman says
that's great and then the press so he
goes are there any questions he should
ask the staff which I which to me it
which was the closest sort of moment of
sort of establishing you know some kind
of framework for for what what story
they were we're expecting do you I don't
mean this to be a contentious question
but do you think I mean obviously your
pieces created some controversy among
your colleagues do you think it is a
fair to hang out with somebody over a
long period of time or even a short
period of time and kind of you know go
drinking with them listen tonight I
didn't drink okay good I own retiring
which they're getting hammered and have
you read Rolling Stone
ya know it hang out with somebody and
and kind of hear they're kind of
off-the-cuff comments they were outside
cuff comments I'm not saying that I'm
going to contest every inaccurate thing
you say so that's just jokes the jokes
and I'm not saying they're irrelevant
jokes but just comments things people
say if that you know banter Shanter
among them III know it but let me finish
do you think it's fair to divert this
before that's why and we came into a
into a kind of larger portrait sure I
think the key in this sense was that
these weren't just offhand come for
comments that got directly at the idea
of civil military relations and the
civil military relationship is the key
component to our counterinsurgency
strategy in Afghanistan so when you had
the top general of the war showing such
disdain and his staff and his staff and
the general is responsible for the
command climate when you had the top
gentleman of the war and his staff
consistently making comments that were
derogatory about hit the civilian
leadership whether they were justified
or not to make those comments that to me
was clearly clearly important and a born
story to tell mm-hmm
Wilbert can you tell us that this kind
of quickly how journalism attracted you
when you were in Angola and and what it
meant to you and what it did for you I
discovered in when I got off death what
I discovered myself and you know what
was at that time the bloodiest prison in
the United States and I saw things that
were just absolutely horrific I had
never you know been in a world like this
before and and I just couldn't believe
that people knew what was going on they
couldn't know the rest of society could
know because if they did know
that go-forward was going on and you
know you send people to prison yes to be
punished but not not what's taken place
in the prison and I had by then I
decided I wanted to be a writer so I
decided I would try telling what was
going on and I said I'd broke newspapers
and asked for a forum and the only one
that answered me back was a chain of
black weeklies for Louisiana and
Mississippi who said hey we'd go for
we'd like to have a column a weekly
column from you called a jungle and
because that's what that's where I saw
the prison a jungle and I started with
writing a weekly column I didn't know
who was reading me as it turned out
several years later the director a brand
new director of Corrections came in and
he had been reading me and he liked what
he read and he felt that I wanted to
tell the truth about what was going on
so we he also felt that a big problem in
prison and the misconceptions that both
to keeping the kept had about each other
and reason they were so ready to believe
the waste of each other was because of
the way they perceived each other and he
felt that a free press you know the
press plays this role out in the streets
in the free world
it said it educates people about people
you know both sides everybody and he
felt that if you could transfer this if
you could pass that you see in the past
information was passed through a prison
grapevine and if you could just transfer
that over to a legitimate forum and
that's a free press then it would you
know maybe it could change things and he
asked if I'd do it and I told him honor
if it was wasn't sensitive and he
surprised the hell out of me by just
okay you know I yet understand
censorship has been a religion has been
practiced universally in America's
prisons forever and this was the first
time and that's the way it happened he
just it okay
you know and we shook hands on it but
there was a condition we were given the
power to investigate photograph anything
we could substantiate and publish any
story just so long as the truth and if
we didn't know the truth at least make
an honest effort to find out what truth
is and his thinking was that you know
the prison was so horrific what are you
hiding it for you know if the public
knew the truth perhaps they would be
moved to change things and that was the
whole gist of it and did it do you find
it did help bridge the gap between the
those who were being kept and those who
are doing the keeping it did they got to
understand each other and because what
we did is we wrote about both sides we
covered it like a community the same way
the Washington Post covers Washington DC
and everything goes that's what we did
and we tried to be a very real
publication even though we're all
self-talk journalist we didn't know what
we're doing but we had an idea by you
know you read other publications see
what they do and okay let's try to do
the same thing and that's the way we did
it and we thought we were done pretty
good well you certainly had a number of
major stories about you know sex slaves
about the defective electric chair that
was burning people how well the the the
the defective lecture chair we did that
because we discovered there was some
photographs and when I discovered about
the photographs I realized that they
were in court
and none of the other news media would
publish it and I mean the most effective
way to do this is you know if you're
going to if you're going to do something
you ought to be able to at least look at
what you do if you can't look at it then
maybe you shouldn't be doing it
so we we published them we got the
pictures and we published the pictures
and what was the reaction among the
other inmates the other prisoners
especially say to the story about about
sex on sex most of the prisoners as a
rule whether they engaged in it only in
sexual violence of they didn't they did
not like the story because they didn't
want people their friends and relatives
in the outside world I think that they
had anything to do with this kind of
stuff that was going on because I
understand what we did at that time
prison authorities nationwide used to
portray sexual violence as isolated
incidents and they were done by gay
inmates so you know widows and the
reality were it heterosexuals were doing
this and the gay in majors quite often
with victims and it was done with the
tacit approval of the administration
although they would say hey we feel like
we've got nothing to do with it you know
we can't control this well they were
doing it and because it divided inmates
as long as you've got one segment of
being made in a population controlling
the other and they're slaves well you
know it makes the prison a whole lot
easier to run and we were able to get
because of this director of Corrections
who ordered everybody to answer
questions whenever we ask them about
their job they had to tell the truth if
I wanted to see a receipt they had to
let me see it but no personal stuff this
long as its business and we have to run
the stories by anyone by the warden
before printing them we have to we had
to get
we had to run it through
Peggy Gresham she was our supervisor at
the time and she was the assistant to
the warden because the warden didn't
have time to deal with that so she ready
and all she want in fact she went back
to school and took a six month I think
studied journalism just to see what it's
about you know to be a more effective
supervisor because she knew what the
what the director wanted he wanted a
very real publication just like the New
York Times The Washington Post than any
other and he took pride in it especially
after we started winning awards but you
know and but the thing is we were able
in the sexual violence thing is that we
were able to get officials from wardens
chief of security everybody to admit
what they were doing they admitted goes
on yes they do have these accommodations
yes security forces do this and they
admitted that's first time that an
administration just admitted that happen
in fact they reported that at the next
American Correctional Convention they
were bar-coded by some of the other
correctional administrators because they
couldn't understand why they let that
cat out of the bag
let me ask just quickly each one of you
four about the impact of your stories
Dana do you think the black sites which
created a huge furor when that story was
printed still exists no no Obama ordered
the last ones
well actually Bush ordered the last one
except ordered all the prisoners sent to
Guantanamo there were 14 of them that
were still left in the black sites by
the time he did that which was about a
year after the story's ran and then
closed the final one in after Obama came
came became president they closed the
final one which was in Afghanistan so
there are no black sites and
have led to a number of investigations
on Capitol Hill which is a little ironic
because some of those people that were
calling for investigations knew what was
happening but when the Democrats had
little power at the time the stories
were published they said very little and
when they became the majority then they
started using it for political advantage
and and and really that's when things
started happening although overseas in
Europe they immediately had many
investigations every country in Europe
was that was acquired almost by the
population to investigate and to say
whether they had a secret prison and of
course the way that these were arranged
were with the heads of intelligence
agencies or the presidents who usually
were no longer in power so the
governments have all denied that they
had any prisons where they had them
however there are playing records that
show the planes landed in certain places
and so they're you know there's a belief
about where they were you think but
things have your articles definitely
changed the entire set right in this
case I think it's it's more of a diffuse
issues you know because we're dealing
with the whole system there have been a
number of investigations launched and
Gates has said that he wants to review
all intelligence programs to cut out
redundancy I think it's it is something
that's moving but it's at it's at a
slower pace because again there are 18
agencies are all separate and
independent the budgeting process is
what it is Congress has a lot of best of
interests and not changing things and
who wants to ever say we're not spending
enough on counterterrorism Adam as the
New Orleans Police Department you think
changed in any significant way as a
result of Jephunneh I'm going to prison
yeah just last week in a man who shot
and had now saved as best seen
since I started to cycled reporting in
2007 eight people have been indicted as
a result of the reporting so there was
one person who was affiliated was
indicted on hate crimes charges for
shooting an african-american man in the
face allegedly because of his race
then there were two officers indicted
for lying about their shooting of a man
in the back after Hurricane Katrina he
died and then there were the five
officers who were indicted in connection
to killing Henry Glover and like you
said one of them got 25 years another
one got 17 years a third is waiting
sentencing and two of them were
acquitted but more broadly you know what
what I've thought about doing these
stories over the last 10 years is that
those things helped reform institutions
sending people to prison for killing
citizens that helps reform them it
doesn't do enough though it's the
beginning of that process and the kind
of broader process is underway in New
Orleans in that the federal government
Justice Department started a civil side
investigation of the police part they
started saying well hey we want to go
beyond just you know charging people in
these individual cases and they released
158 page report of their findings
documenting systemic ongoing civil
rights violations by the department what
is likely to happen is the Department of
Justice will go into court with the
police department they will get a
consent decree that will lead to a judge
monitoring the department over three or
five or an unlimited number of years and
there will probably be a 30 to 50 point
check that will be hey these are the
things you need to improve in the
department citizen complaints so
citizens can actually complain and have
their complaints heard internal affairs
so that officers actually effectively
investigate misconduct by other officers
use of force so that people aren't
getting shot in the back unnecessarily
and that process is likely to go on for
years but it has the possibility of
dramatically transforming the department
in a way that goes beyond just sending a
handful of officers to prison mm-hmm
Michael you've been back to Iraq since
your article do you think there's been
any shift or change in that relationship
between the civilian electorate leaders
and the people actually running the war
in which the Power had gravitated or
maybe even was taken by the military
ones and also any change in you you
emphasize this very important strategic
policy in which they try to minimize
civilian casualties that make soldiers
feel they were more at risk has there
been a change in that with it with the
change in command or is is a military
just such a large reading organization
that it doesn't change very easily well
I think there's still pretty significant
problems civil military problems and and
we're going to see that play out in the
next few months as the White House tries
to push for a drawdown of American
troops on the July 2011 deadline and
General Petraeus no Pentagon is going to
really try to resist that in terms of
this the civilian casualties issue
airstrikes are up so that that's pretty
significant night raids are up these are
all incidents that that would that would
lead to tend to lead to more civilian
casualties and there was also an
incident where a whole town was was a
wiped out and then we're now rebuilding
it no one there are no cows is there but
but clearly I think though they say they
say there's no difference in the rules
of engagement there actually has been a
loosening of them mm-hmm
then it a new piece you said there were
eight hundred and fifty-four thousand
people who had top-secret clearance that
does not even include a previously
obscure private and Bradley Manning who
I think only had clearance for
classified information there must be
over a million people
who have that how if there's so many
people who have access to classified or
top-secret information if it's so widely
disseminated how can you keep it secret
and should you keep it secret well there
are secrets that I think should be
secret I mean I give you one example
nuclear codes you know how you how you
make a nuclear weapon viable and many
others I mean that would never argue
that there aren't but every every panel
of the you know body that's have looked
at classification issues in a systematic
way has always said things are over
classified and the incentive is to
classify something you know that's the
safe way the in the end why risk not
doing enough let's do too much so you
know that that is one that's one issue
the there's pretty draconian methods for
keeping people having clearances I mean
they do background checks they that are
get very personal with you if you're at
a top-secret level they have a secret
court that rules on these issues you
don't have as much as many rights as you
would in a normal court and because
there's an economic incentive to keep
your clearance because you can make so
much more money in the private sector
with the clearance you know people do
people are pretty careful however it's
this other thing that is happening these
two things are happening in parallel one
is the government is classifying as it
has been for years over classifying
things and then hiding them in you know
separate compartments that get cut up
into little different into layers of
secrecy and that's one big problem we
found on the other hand because of
Technology and social media and what you
can do with a computer you have
WikiLeaks and I don't think that that is
going
to necessarily stop because there are
many ways to penetrate systems that are
supposed to be secure and as as this one
as this episode is shown also people
said well why would private Manning have
access to those cables I think it's a
pretty darn good question I mean I don't
at all I support in I mean I have big
problems with with Julian Assange and
his personality but the information that
has come out in the WikiLeaks cables is
fascinating it's important
by and large shows the government doing
things I think in the right way way it
and and it's had tremendous
international it's a tremendous
international for Tunisia and been oh
right and I think that's also where you
know how far if our foreign policy rests
on falsehoods to the public and secrecy
with dictators it's going to be
vulnerable but how about this notion
that diplomats should have a right to
cable back home what they think of a
leader or to point out the leaders
family is corrupt what what do you think
Adam do you think Julian Assange who
describes himself as a reporter is in
fact functioning as a reporter do you
think what he did was heroic valuable
deplorable lots a lot of questions yeah
well here you know for I mean the first
thing is that I think wow you know to me
I see the parallels between the cables
that we learned about from the Church
Commission hearings back in the 70s
they're not dramatic like those like hey
like let's top o the I end a government
but it's interesting that you know 40
years later we have these same sort of
revelations coming from that
communications mode do I think what he
did was heroic I don't know I don't know
that most things are wrong but I think
it's very interesting I think it's had
this incredible obviously had this
incredible impact on our spirit I think
for journalists in one way what the
important thing that it's done is it's
made the idea of journalism the concept
of journalism interesting to people
beyond our circles that people started
talking about journalism again they
started talking about important stories
because of that and I think that that is
weirdly and interesting and important
impact that he's had that that's had is
he a journalist or not I think that he's
a I think that he's a person who's found
a way to get very important get very
useful information out of a specific
target group and part of his target
group are other hacker type computer and
expert nerds who have access to this
information and those are not often
people that we as journalists think
about cultivating as sources you know
and that's that's kind of a genius move
frankly could I read a comment that from
a column Bill Keller wrote last week in
The Sunday Times magazine that gives a
sense of this this new world we've
entered it says the digital age has
changed the dynamics of disobedience in
at least one respect it used to be that
someone who wanted to cheat on his vow
of secrecy had to work at it Daniel
Ellsberg tried for a year to make the
Pentagon Papers public there was a lot
of time to have second thoughts or to
get caught it is now at least
theoretically possible for a
whistleblower or a trader to act almost
immediately and anonymously click on a
website upload a file go home and wait
what do you think Michael about the
whole WikiLeaks business is it changed
journalism forever or is that an area do
you think you know getting into
computers is something that journalists
should know more about and begin to
cultivate well I mean I think in terms
of mr. Keller's description of of that I
don't actually that's accurate in terms
of what Bradley Manning actually did
which was over a period of time you know
he had elite speaking of Lady gaga it
was
Mena's Lady Gaga CD that he popped in to
download the files at great risk to
himself being uh where he was was in a
rocky I don't think he was described he
saving idea world now in which this kind
of thing can happen yeah and I think I
mean I think in terms of of uh you know
does it does the internet look there's
so much data on internet that's so
vulnerable uh I mean one of the
interesting things that this a not this
group called anonymous who are a bunch
of hacktivists uh who are the defenders
of WikiLeaks uh you know hacked into
these this email account of this
contracting agency in found tons of
incredible material so does it change
journal I I'm very wary of any any sort
of pronouncements about oh the future of
journalism has changed it's just another
way to get more information and one of
the defining things a lot of the blog
post it always say you know WikiLeaks
now fulfills the the watchdog function
that traditional media has failed to do
but then they'll put the exception
except for Dana priests at the
Washington Post you know who does a
great job of the of the of the watch
that's it but but I think it's quite
interesting that that clearly what
Assange has done is fulfil a great need
of this idea to sort of pierce through
the secrecy in a way that that no one
else has been able to do well I think
we're approaching question time so if
you do have a question come down to
either side of the aisle line up in
front of the mic
meanwhile I'll just ask quickly have you
faced reprisals for anything you've
written or threats I know you had some
problems I think after well the black
sites prison yeah
after the blight black sites stories the
House and Senate leaders called for an
investigation out of the black sites but
of the Washington Post and
and their surrogates went on TV and
remember this is a different time and
their surrogates went on television and
called for the same thing and worse and
it did create a real hostility I mean I
got very I got bad emails I got emails
that weren't civil I got emails over
threatening that sort of thing yeah
Michael did you encounter a lot of
complaints cripes that's it's it's
interesting I mean one of the sort of
interesting aspects to the story and you
touched upon in your question I mean in
the sort of questioning period here I
was the only one you asked should you
have reported the story you know that
was the question you sort of you should
have posed to me and and that was a
response that a number of other
journalists had as well and to meet it
what it illuminated was this sort of
extremely cozy relationship that then
that many in my profession have
established with with very powerful
figures and how much they cherish that
relationship and the idea that anyone
could threaten that you know causes
great great concern so so the most sort
of vicious kind of attacks I always get
are from from my normal of my colleagues
no and but all but I think one of the
reasons why I think it's somewhat
ridiculous some of the some of the
criticisms is that basically the
criticism is wait this guy wrote down
what he heard and saw wait a minute
we're not supposed to do that literally
those are almost direct quotes from what
what people were saying and and as I
said you know that this is sort of a
theme that's that's now then you are if
general McChrystal was not a powerful
person if he was a leader of a gang and
I wrote down what he said no one
would've been on t on CNN saying hey
wait was that off-the-record you know I
mean so that that's uh that's what I
just say about that have you faced
difficulties because of what you've
written yeah you know there were there
were a couple dicey moments in New
Orleans we were doing the hate crime
story we made contact with somebody in
the neighborhood where the hate crime
had occurred and leisurely occurred and
this person said you know don't come
here we know who you are we know who did
these shootings we don't have a problem
with it if you come over here you know
expect that your life is in serious
jeopardy you know so and did you go over
there oh yeah I mean we know like look I
mean like reporting in America like
being a cab drivers are much more
dangerous profession than being a
journalist you know and so you get those
things that I don't take them that
seriously you know it's more dangerous
to do a lot of other things much more
names like be a journalistic will be a
James it eggs all over you I really
reference for reference between what he
was done and what we were doing is that
you know they'll write him a letter to
the editor about his stories didn't
exactly write letters to the editor you
know the right ship it you do with a
baseball bat but now we did I mean there
are times you you go on high alert you
know that what you're going to you get a
feel for you for you for what you know
the tolerance level of people you write
read it and you know that hey this is
going to this is going to mess up some
heads and some security or this is going
to mess up a straighten gangsters head
and but you it's like is it you can't
function intimidate it certainly not in
the prison I mean you can functional
Taliban law here but not in the prison
he'll eat your life if it sir you have a
question to say that I think my Cola has
given a good account of himself as in
fact following a certain number of rules
like for example he has said that he
hadn't he didn't write down off the
comic off-the-cuff comments or some
some rule of that kind I was wondering
when it comes down to the bottom line
what kind of rule ground rules Michael
are you stating for you're hanging out
with McChrystal and and was it his fault
perhaps that he didn't follow these
ground rules that you have in mind
if he'd expected to be fired if you'd
shown him what you were going to write
he would have tried to withdraw I
wouldn't do
perhaps he he might have felt that you
didn't warn him that you were going to
put all this stuff down and somehow get
it out
sure well I guess I think the question I
guess I would say that there's a and I'm
not trying to be a smartass here um
though it takes effort for me sometimes
I apologize for that I there's there's
four decades worth at least of what a
magazine profile looks like and when a
public figure invites a magazine
journalists to tag along with them even
if it's just for an hour or if it's for
two days or four it's for a month I
would suggest that a good rule of thumb
is your expectation of privacy is much
diminished and in fact things that you
saved the journalist that he writes down
might end up in print so so I and this
is it's actually interesting question
what did they expect of the story uh and
and and I don't I don't know what they
what exactly they would they they sort
of expected but but I think a it was a
double-edged sword because they wanted
they were they were sort of they were
performing for the audience of Rolling
Stone in a way to I think this is what
I've always sort of thought and they
knew what sort of made a good Rolling
Stone story so this idea of them you
know partying in in in Paris or hanging
out and being these kind of macho super
talented brilliant guys that they are I
I always thought that that was part of
it that part of it was for wood they
were sort of uh it was the the light so
I actually expected yeah and and I don't
know I mean it would be interesting to
see what what they end up I will wind up
saying uh I haven't talked to them
because
hasn't sort of publicly commented on on
the story except for his initial apology
for this this whole issue I just wanna
interject of profiles and what you
reveal and don't reveal has been going
then discussed for years and years some
of you may remember 1989 article by
Janet Mellon called the journalist and
the murderer in which he wrote about Joe
McGinnis who began a book on a man named
Geoffrey McDonald telling McDonald that
he believed he was innocent and thereby
gaining access to some private papers
and then when the book came out it was a
kind of strong case for his conviction
if I remember the first sentence of the
article it is a shocking opening but it
says any journalist who is not a fool or
not so full of himself that he doesn't
know what is going on will admit that
what he does is morally indefensible
that's quite a sweeping indictment of
the field but there are there it created
a furor because there are sometimes
little betrayals that go on in any
profile writing that is to say you don't
always open up and tell the person what
you're expecting and you're looking for
things I mean it's a natural under the
it's not up to the journalist to narrow
their own field of what's permissible to
write it's up to the subject to set the
ground rules if they want to limit what
is on or off or on background why would
a journalist Hank up themselves unless
of course the subject and it's not the
case here or in the case I think with
probably Janet Malcolm's subject if it's
somebody who doesn't know much about
journalism somebody from the street is
being interviewed I think that's a I
think journalists are under an
obligation to vary but if you're in the
public eye yeah you have a staff of
public affairs people it is their
responsibility to set and maintain in
one sense and you and you've risen up to
the highest blood come and it's kind
strange udo sir hi I'm glad you
mentioned that taxi driving is more
dangerous than journalism because I
wanted to ask a question about a
journalist who was a taxi driver an
American journalist at the same time and
is now on death row Mumia abu-jamal
I want to ask something especially mr.
Rideau but all of you if you feel any
connection with him and as the community
of journalists if you feel any passion
about about his plight it's also
connected to Bradley Manning for me
who's a whistleblower who's now in
prison and it's a lot of being written
about his rights being violated as well
as Mumia abu-jamal
rights q do you want to handle it I
don't mind the only thing I mean I don't
know that much about Jamal's case
unfortunately you know a lot of people
who in caught up in the criminal justice
system and I don't know all that case
some of the more famous and I still
don't know and but you know you which I
think what you're saying is like you
know there's a fellowship or community
of journalists or something and it's
their feelings about I don't know you
know as I attempt to try to answer your
question I don't know how to answer your
question I am concerned that you know I
don't know its case well enough to know
whether or not he's been treated fairly
or unfairly I don't know much about it I
think there's not going to be a say
notice Exedy anyone want a hat my hope
is that he would be treated fairly
because I know what it's like not to be
treated fairly
like what did you McClatchy Newspapers
just wrote a great editorial about
Bradley Manning
that media outlet should actually chip
in for his defense - and not just the
defense of WikiLeaks if the government
said to prosecute a case and I think
there's a compelling argument to be made
that to see you know if he is the great
one of the sort of great sources of
journalistic history where newspapers
and magazines use his stuff all the time
the stuff that he leaked all the time I
think there's something to be said to
advocate on his behalf so he doesn't
spend the rest of his life in jail this
is probably mostly for Michael but I
throw it out for the rest of the panel -
what do you think the legacy of the Pat
Tillman case is for journalists and also
for the country I think the legacy in my
speaking personally what Pat Tillman's
family did to uncover the truth was
incredible gut wrenching I don't know
how they how they did it and kept at it
for so long and and so that that's just
sort of my personal feeling about it
clearly there's always going to be the
the pentagon's always going to want to
spin the hero myth right away and I
think it always makes sense to sort of
step back from that but to me the legacy
is the fact that his family has been
able to tell his story so gripping ly
and compellingly
and keep it in the public's mind and
it's also a good tale or a good reminder
of how institutions are self protected
so protective and that you know it takes
work to get sunshine on the facts that
they're by nature like that that's why
we have that's why we have protections
because you know the founders figure
that out a long time ago and set it up
that way so that we could keep poking at
the think about are you witty tech oh
yeah I have a couple of quick questions
for Dana to what extent do you think
this internal security - intelligence
apparatus that you uncovered is directed
outward towards enemies foreign and to
what extent is it directed inward and
how do you see that trending and also to
what extent do you believe these various
and corporate you know agencies operate
through soft power like disinformation
and misinformation using their
connections into what extent do they
operate through hard power like making
people disappear and extraordinary
rendition things like that and how do
you see that trending okay
well because the Defense Department is
the largest by far the largest of all
the intelligence agencies they really
are directed outward and so even we've
looked at their presence in the United
States and they're you know they have a
bigger mission now in the United States
because of North the Northern Command
but it's not really very interesting so
most of it is directed outward however
and this was the fourth article that I
did was on the domestic the domestic
situation and I looked at the FBI the
Department of Homeland Security and and
some other things and really there is a
incremental creeping trend towards
putting things about you in a database
because you might have done something
that some local police officer some
shopkeeper some person walking on the
street might have thought was looked
suspicious they can get you into a
database that you won't have the right
fit to know about it's called The
Guardian the FBI's Guardian database and
and because of Technology I mean
commercially available I I know this
because I asked my researcher to do this
we have this commercially available
technology that allows us I mean I can
find anybody social security in here I
can find out probably what credit cards
you have where you where you've lived
since you were 18 it's all it's all
there and the companies they can find
out your spending habits
you know an awful lot about you well all
of that now is available to the police
to to the to the FBI so because of
commercial trends and because of this
dragnet approach
is what how I view it is that they are
you know this whole report suspicious
activities campaign it's really a
dragnet approach to send everybody out
there cast the big net you know see if
there's any interesting fish to come
along and the ones that they don't
really know about the put them in the
database anyway in case they can find
something down the road instead of using
what has worked out a little bit better
is FBI focused counterterrorism
investigations with some help from from
others so so that's the first one and
the second one I don't remember what is
your well oh soft in the hard power you
know I don't believe I believe that most
of these agencies operate not in any
rogue manner they operate under the
rules that they are that are passed by
lawyers and various ways I mean the
renditions the extraordinary renditions
the secret prisons they were all signed
off on by the Office of Legal Counsel
and the General Counsel's at the CIA so
they were all approved so I don't
believe that people in the United States
disappear and that I'm not a believer in
conspiracy theories because the
government's in general it's about you
general to bollixed up to sort of
complete a conspiracy but they're not
very good at using soft power especially
when it comes to counterterrorism where
you see the military again is the is the
big player there and they're not and
they're not equipped or trained to use
soft power and the institutions that are
the State Department being an AI D which
is completely atrophied into a contract
agency they are bad at it and
under-resourced and there's no hope in
the future I don't think that they're
going to get any better because they
have no constituency in Congress and a
little of it in the United States and
for
Michael Joshua Kors the Nation magazine
I appreciate your energy and your
reporting and I want to ask you about
your position as a freelancer in the
past year I uncovered pretty grave
crimes committed by top officials in the
US Army and I presented those to
producers at the major networks all of
them said to me you know this is really
important we have no doubt that this is
true we're not going to run this story
and one of them put it to me very
bluntly he said look we're not michael
hastings
we have a relationship with the top
officials at the Pentagon revealing
these crimes would irrevocably damaged
that relationship Michael can come
report the truth and disappear we can't
do that is there a question question is
I will well do you believe do you
believe that that's true well I mean I
think what day thanks for your kind
words and also I get the nation on my
Kindle all the time so I'll be looking
for your byline or once a week not all
the time what a what every story you
have give me shoot me an email we'll
talk to my toes at Rolling Stone and no
I think look Rolling Stone has uh David
in my view they've been doing great
stuff with Matt Taibbi Tim Dickinson um
a number of journals like I could list
off in one of their functions is to uh
not have to worry about things like that
like we're able to go there because we
don't have a table at the White House
Correspondents Dinner you know uh and
but but I think also one of the things
is that I talk to people at the Pentagon
all the time still you know and and and
they talk to me not sometimes because
they want to not because they like me or
like my socks you know they they
you know they they talk to me because
they know it's in there it's in their
interest to to say okay we better oh
it's that Hastings guy better you know
respond to his email even if it's just
to tell them to go have a nice day
so so I think my experiences has been
you know you can do these stories and
and it's not in fact it has more
benefits than than drawbacks we have
time probably for only one or two more
yes just a few simple questions
do you believe journalists are
responsible chiefly to the public
government or personal interest when
investigating and what are the risks
that journalism stake in revealing a
story so anybody who is willing time so
couldn't hear the second question what
are the risks that are taken when you
reveal a story I think we've covered
that second one pretty much the threats
and things like that and the first
question again is do you chiefly report
when you report and investigate is it to
the public government or your personal
interests in following up various
stories I guess Eric where's my boss
stories I mean when you when you
investigate under stories who do you is
it chiefly um you believe that it's to
the public to the government or because
you're interested in investigating this
story no it's it's both it's the stories
that compel me that I feel like are
worth working with my team working with
my colleagues going after for years to
get and it's stories that I think matter
that have are going to have some impact
in the world and that's why I want to do
them and occasionally they end up being
like aliens one in space no one can hear
you scream and nobody actually cares
about your story but it's great when
they do and that's why I want to do that
is is for the broader public a Wilbur
what would you say your motivation
can you can you try and explain that
when I was when you were doing all these
inaudible stole my motive was to try to
I was all about trying to make a
difference you know I mean you know it's
it's not that many people get
opportunity in life to have the power to
really make a difference for good I mean
and to see the changes I mean in you
know in prison being editor and being
gentle and I can just pick out whichever
I know which what a problem is quite
often I knew what the story was before
you even start investigating it and I
know what the outcome is going to be and
you just pick one and for the same
reason he said the one that excites you
the most and the one that will have the
greatest impact and will make the
biggest difference and you also the
other thing you have to always after you
do all that you figure out okay
can you stand the heat you know will it
bring you down
most often I say most of it never
brought us down you know we were always
able to stand the heat but that was it
it's just it's a great feeling you know
when you can do something and you know
the thing I always love is when I finish
the story the greatest compliment you
could tell me except to say say man look
I didn't agree with you but you know I
didn't know that that's all I wanted to
hear just tell me you didn't know it
because I've done my job last question
so I apologize this is also for mr.
Hastings you mentioned earlier that your
story exposed the contempt for civilians
in the military's top brass well it's
not a bit redundant in the sense that
when you wage a war it already shows
contempt for civilians
I apologize that's a bit rhetorical but
my second second part of the question is
do you get the sense
covering the war in Afghanistan and the
wars in Iraq and how these guys are
perpetually dragging their foot when
people call for a deadline to end this
war that and you mentioned that they're
still continuing these night raids
continuing airstrikes do you think that
there's a sense that they want the
public in America and perhaps even the
public in these occupied countries to
get use used used to the idea of
civilian deaths well in terms of the
sort of the question should asking that
kind of what does it mean to be kind of
at war for the last decade and then
recently you know a recent excursion in
Libya as well and I think whether they
whether it's intentional or not I think
it's clear that the we as the public me
as a human being and a journalist we get
immune to to what happens to civilians
death especially when it happens in
another country so but I I don't know I
don't know if that's the intent but
that's certainly the consequence where I
mean in one of the one of the sort of
weird ironies was that you you could
write you can write a story I mean
Rolling Stone the story last week about
the kill team which had these really
horrific photos about this this
community of American soldiers that had
gone out and killed innocent civilians
and set them up and did really really
horrific stuff and it captured the news
cycle for about 48 hours you know but
it's really even it is one of those rare
issues where I actually agree with
Secretary of Defense Donald Rumsfeld who
said just yesterday that that story
should have been much more
great and and why is why wasn't it and
you know something screwed up when
Rumsfeld is also reading Rolling Stone
but but there's something to that and
I'm sure you know I actually be curious
to hear what the other panels have to
say in terms of have we gotten
desensitized to some of this news that I
mean the top secret America incredible
jaw-dropping insight and we almost don't
even know how to how to write how do you
interpret it well I think it's it's much
easier to focus attention on a single
thing like in your case a person in the
Walter Reed case when we did the stories
about the bad conditions there I mean
that's one institution so people know
how to respond but when you're talking
about large things like war and you know
systems it's it's very difficult to
respond the Rolling Stone story about
the kill teams you know I think what
that is is reader fatigue and you always
face it as a journalist I mean first you
face editor fatigue so you're going to
do one more story about what you know
and I mean that's what we don't have I
think we have a lack of imagination
about reporting on poverty here economic
downturn what that did to people our
editors wanted those stories on the
other hand what they didn't want and I
don't think you want either is a story
where you start to read the first
paragraph and you kind of know what the
story is going to say I'm not saying
that's what the kill team stories was
like we're like if that calls upon I
actually I think that makes a great case
for the new platforms that we have at
our fingertips but are still not really
using to their full extent because you
can combine the written word with voices
with video and make something all more
powerful and seem new because you know
every every incident actually is new for
those involved great just what so one
more question please I consider to be
one of the panels on press a time
pushing forget again to go for a mom oh
well that in my opinion the two Venom's
two prints and that is aggregators and
the internet and since print relies
excessively or readily on ad do your
investigative reports conflict with
sponsors we had an interesting case in
top secret America first of all no they
don't I mean we were separate you know
so if there's someone in the advertising
department who doesn't they never
discuss anything with the newsroom about
what they should or shouldn't be doing
because of my lose or gain ads in fact
they make a point if there's a story
about you know a car like there's a
story that criticizes or glorifies
something they will not put an ad that's
in the related field next to it and the
same thing happened with the top secret
America they decided on the websites
they would have no ads for the first
many first month I think it was just I
don't know in readers minds sometimes we
don't do a good job explaining ourselves
you know explaining those kind of things
explaining that the editorial page is
not the same as a news page it's church
and state we don't talk to each other
they obviously don't read our paper
sometimes positions they do but a long
time ago an editor told me no one's ever
going to buy an ad to put next to one of
your he was kind of telling I would like
to thank our panel I think is gray
it was good